[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
This is your TLDR.
Learn to use the Google
Play Developer Console
to understand how players
are progressing, spending,
and churning with
this new sample game.
Produced with the help
from Auxbrain, developer
of Zombie Highway 2, it uses
randomized and anonymized data
from a real game.
If you use Google+ features
with your Play Games Permission,
check out this blog post for
changes that could impact you.
We're taking steps
to reduce sign
in friction and unnecessary
permission requests
by moving the game's
APIs to a new model.
Android Marshmallow
introduced several changes
that were designed to help
your app look after user data.
To help you make use
of those changes,
this post highlights the key
considerations for user trust
when it comes to run time
permissions and hardware
identifiers.
Check it out.
Now if you're a student
who loves to code
or has a great idea
for a mobile app,
the AdMob student challenge is
your chance to build an app,
learn how to make money from it,
and win awesome prizes, which
include a week long trip to
San Francisco and a visit
to the Googleplex.
App Invites is an out
of the box solution
for conducting app referrals
and encouraging sharing.
Here's some details on how two
apps, Fabulous and Yummly used
App Invites to grow
their user base.
Also in the case study category,
it turns out design matters.
Check out this new
video with Wego
and learn how they increased
monthly user retention by 300%,
and reduced uninstall rates by
up to 25% with Material Design.
Now this is a
really cool article
from Google Research on
mastering the ancient game
of Go with machine learning.
Using a single machine,
AlphaGo one all but
one of its 500 games against
several top Go programs.
So you know, they went ahead and
challenged the reigning three
time European Go champion,
an elite professional player
who has devoted his life
to Go since the age of 12.
Check out the article to see
how that match turned out.
Cloud9 is a development
environment in the cloud.
And you can now easily
create a new Cloud9 workspace
connected with a Google
Cloud Platform project.
It comes preinstalled with the
Cloud SDK and G Cloud command
line tool, and allows
you to build and deploy
your app to Google App Engine
directly within the IDE.
The Chrome 48 beta includes
a new security panel
and dev tools that makes
deploying HTTPS easier.
The security panel displays
connection information
for every network request,
demystifying the connection
errors that keep you away
from the green lock that
represents a secure connection.
Oh, and if you
didn't know already,
Android Studio is faster.
Here's Reto Meier
to tell you more.
RETO MEIER: Hey,
get back to work.
MALE SPEAKER: Building
and deploying.
RETO MEIER: Oh.
Well, then download
Android Studio 2.0,
and your incremental
builds will be instant.
MALE SPEAKER: Who's
doing what now?
RETO MEIER: Don't let
this happen to you.
I'm Reto Meier, and this
is "Who's Doing What Now?"
As developers, we all
know that the number one
excuse for legitimately
slacking off
is building and
deploying your app.
Until now, hitting build
and run was an opportunity
to take a break, grab some
coffee, catch up on the news,
or look at some cats.
Now thanks to the
Android Studio team,
those glory days are over.
Android Studio 2.0 has
arrived with a new incremental
build feature, which
makes your builds now take
seconds instead of minutes.
When you first run your
app, the normal compile,
dx, package, deploy,
install, and run
steps all happen as
normal, though much faster
thanks to significant
improvements
to dx, ProGuard,
shrinker, and adb.
From then on,
pressing Instant Run
will deploy your changes
directly into the running app.
And Android Studio will
update your application logic
and resources.
So you can see the changes
appear near instantly.
This feature is
designed to be magical.
So you stay in the flow
while coding, building,
and running your app.
No more breaks in
concentration, waiting around,
or switching contexts.
It works with the
emulator, physical devices,
and it works all the
way back to API 15.
Developers reducing their
average build and deploy
cycles, staying in the zone,
and increasing productivity--
that's "Who's Doing What Now."
Get back to work.
MALE SPEAKER: Running
the test suite.
RETO MEIER: Oh, carry on.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that's your
"Developer Show" for this week.
Remember to use the
hashtag, #AskDevShow
to get your questions answered.
And don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
to get the show every week.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]